good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson and happy monday
joe biden may have lost a step along the
way but his handlers work
fast within hours of the inauguration in
january biden's white house opened
america's borders to the world not
simply to job seekers and gang members
from mexico and central america
but to varieties of illegal migrants
from all over the globe from
africa and asia from the middle east
virtually
anyone who could get to mexico was and
is admitted into the united states
without a visa in some cases foreign
nationals whose identities we cannot
verify
were flown to the interior of our
country and permanently resettled
without the permission of the people who
already live there
americans how did migrants get from
congo to lewiston maine and why
well because susan rice and audiologs
like her very much want to change
maine's demographics as well as the
population mix in every other state in
the union
so the administration is working to do
that by fiat without a vote in congress
without public consent of any kind
by definition this is the most radical
possible attack on the core premise of
democracy
which is that citizens get to run their
own countries not foreigners
citizens the leaders of the democratic
party though no longer believe
in democracy as constituted and they
definitely don't plan to lose another
election
so as the rest of us go about our lives
they're importing huge numbers of new
voters into the united states
when you say this out loud they become
absolutely hysterical and call you names
but they do that only because it's so
obviously true
unfortunately for susan rice this is one
change to the country that's pretty hard
to hide
if you live within 100 miles of the
mexican border for example you watch it
happen in real time
on the border the rule of law has been
suspended the american system of order
and decency and
fairness is being mocked and destroyed
by the very people in charge of
sustaining it you don't have to be a
conservative republican to be deeply
offended by what's going on
last november in texas many thousands of
lifelong democrats with mexican last
names
voted for donald trump why because they
knew perfectly well what the left plan
to do to the border
and they were right they're patriotic
americans they didn't want to see their
country destroyed
so for the joe biden administration this
is potentially a very serious political
problem
most people no matter what color they
are no matter who they vote for think
that joe biden's current immigration
policy is lunacy
because it is opening the border is the
single most unpopular thing the white
house has done
so far by far biden's handlers
understand
this could be a disaster for them so
this weekend they dispatched kamala
harris to central america with orders to
pretend she's trying to fix it
harris you may remember is the shallow
political opportunist from canada
we're often told as some kind of civil
rights hero slash moral leader
on sunday harris flew to guatemala to
unveil her policy to address the crisis
what is it in a word the plan is bribery
the administration plans to spend
billions of dollars to pay
latin america's poor not to move to the
united states
cnn of course loves the idea it blames
america
quote kamala harris's visit to central
america singles and
signals a new chapter the channel
slobbered in a headline this morning
but there's nothing actually new about
this we've seen this cartoon before
six years ago as barack obama's vice
president joe biden announced what he
called a
plan for central america in the new york
times
the idea at the time is the idea now
once we send billions to corrupt foreign
governments their citizens will stop
showing up in texas and california
so we tried it how did it work exactly
well let's see
we now have more people from central
america coming over our border illegal
than at any time in decades possibly
ever so it didn't work very well
that's obvious to everyone but joe biden
who doesn't seem to have noticed in
april he told congress that his plan
was a brilliant success when i was vice
president
president asked me to focus on providing
help needed to address the root causes
of migration
and it helped keep people in their own
countries instead of being forced to
leave
the plan was working but the last
administration decided it was not worth
it
i'm restoring the program and asked vice
president harris to lead our diplomatic
effort to take care of this
i have absolute confidence to get the
job done
so the last administration was weak on
border security right okay got it
but the sentence to pay attention to is
the claim that people from central
america are quote
forced to come here who are they forced
to come here by well by
us of course we're not keeping up with
our bribes to the drug traffickers who
run say honduras so it's our fault
better restart the payments immediately
or someone could get hurt
but that's a lie foreign aid almost
never
accomplishes what we pretend it will
accomplish for the people for whom
it's intended and if you think otherwise
how about explaining
africa for more than 50 years the west
the us in particular has bombarded that
continent with taxpayer and ngo money
as well as with all the stupid and very
patronizing assumptions
that accompany that money and the result
is there a single
african country that is better off for
it less corrupt
and more self-sufficient take an hour or
two to check that fact sometime if you
have the time
it's hard to find a single country
foreign aid projects are where liberal
arrogance goes to die they almost never
work
for the people they're supposed to work
for sorry they don't
it sounds like they would but they don't
yesterday even the new york times
conceded this is true
for example over the past 10 years
guatemala alone has received more than a
billion and a half dollars in u.s
aid so what's the result of that aid
small country
billion and a half dollars well
according to the new york times poverty
and malnutrition in guatemala
have now risen to unprecedented levels
really why are you surprised when was
the last time that welfare made someone
stronger or happier
the same is true with countries if
anything joe biden's aid package
encouraged illegal migration to the
united states michael clemons a fellow
at the center for global development
studied the data on this he found that
quote foreign aid focused on economic
development is
actually associated with increases in
emigration from poor countries
but of course that's true the only
surprise is that we would be surprised
healthy places are by definition
self-sufficient
places dependence by contrast breeds
misery
that's always true misery
causes people to flee and they have
kamala harris is no genius obviously but
even she must sense this
she knows more bribes won't work so
instead of defending her plan on the
specifics she's taking the much easier
and far more familiar road
more babbling about racism and sexism
and of course
climate change there are also
long-standing issues
that are often called the root causes of
immigration
we are looking at the issue of poverty
and the lack therefore of economic
opportunities
the issue of extreme weather conditions
and the lack of climate adaptation
as well as corruption and the lack of
good governance
and violence against women indigenous
people
lgbtq people and afrodescendants
often cause called the root causes of
immigration really by whom
exactly no honest person quick kamala
harris
name three global problems of any kind
that are not
caused by racism and sexism and climate
change
and whose solutions don't make you more
powerful
because that's always the acid test of
good faith
does the solution cost you or does it
help you if it helps you
every single time maybe it's not really
a solution
so what's the answer just kidding trick
question obviously there aren't any
global problems
that aren't associated with racism and
sexism and global climate change
and that don't require kamala harris to
become a lot more powerful
the funny thing is and it is funny no
one has told
central americans this they think
they're coming here to brownsville and
san jacedro precisely because
kamala harris is now the vice president
watch
yamate says increased border crossings
have been caused in part
by the change of administrations in
washington
we're going to reunite families and
we're going to reunite children
the very next day the coyotes were here
organizing groups of children to take
them to the united states
we asked the united states government to
send more of a clear message
to prevent more people from leaving
oh so they're not coming here because of
sexism in fact in latin america they
kind of like the patriarchy
sorry kamala harris they're not coming
here
because they're fleeing a culture they
don't like it's their culture
they're coming here because this is a
much richer and much more generous
country and now they can come here
so why wouldn't they it's not their
fault
it's ours and if you really wanted to
solve the problem the answer is pretty
simple you would deport people here
illegally that's what normal countries
do
how much time does mexico or israel
spend blaming itself for people who
break their laws
not a lot of time actually not one
second
they swiftly deport people who do that
and if we did that it would get the
world's attention
immediately because the truth is many of
these countries
need illegal immigrants in our country
in order to continue that's how
unhealthy the economics of this
arrangement are
as of 2019 for example remittances from
immigrants the united states
accounted for fully 20 of el salvador's
entire gdp is that healthy should we
continue that
don't we want an independent el salvador
that can feed itself
clearly we don't care the same was true
essentially in honduras and guatemala
according to a recent piece that moved
on the ap wire so many guatemalans have
left
that much of the country survives on
remittances they send home
once again if you cared about guatemala
you would try to make guatemala
independent you wouldn't make it yet
another third world country dependent on
ngo and foreign aid money that's a
horrible thing to do
it's the same story in mexico by the way
in 2018 then presidential candidate
amlo admitted quote these remittances
are the main
income that this country has more than
oil
more than tourism is that what we want
for mexico
if you cared about mexico would you want
that no it's degrading
and it might be part of the reason
mexico is a disaster in the middle of a
drug war ongoing for 10 years
kamala harris doesn't care so her
solution is the same solution give more
money to the narco states
to honduras where the president is under
a dea investigation for drug trafficking
we are launching our call to action
for businesses to invest in the northern
triangle i believe that
the businesses in particular our private
business sector
have a very significant role to play as
we all know
in creating jobs and promoting economic
opportunity
and in long-term development i am proud
that
we have companies already in the united
states who have
committed to act we have mastercard who
intends to partner
across sectors to bring five million
people in the region
into the digital economy and to support
one million small businesses
this is hilarious only because
no one on the left talks about economics
or understands economics all debates
used to be economics
it's not even mentioned anymore it's all
race and gender but underlying
all of this is economics and what kamala
harris is saying
is that big u.s companies are quote
ready to act selflessly of course
to get more cheap labor in the third
world they're ready to act
even as our own labor market does things
that no
healthy market would do unemployment is
going
up even as businesses can't find labor
to fill
open jobs something very ominous is
happening in our labor markets it's
being ignored so we can help honduras's
labor market on behalf of el salvador
and by the way
send more money to governments that
don't deserve it that are corrupt that
don't serve their own people
in the hope they'll stop invading us but
they'll invade us anyway because
it's been going on for 10 years hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else